okay everyone I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Neil MCD and
Brock Heasley director writer and EP and
actor in it of the shift which is in
theaters now how you guys doing today
that sounds good doesn't it it does
sound
good you Steve doing good uh it's good
to see you guys um so Neil you always
play really good villains and what I
love about this film in particular is
like you really go all out in it and you
do it so great cuz you never go over the
top or cheesy with it how do you find
that sweet spot any secret to
that boy that's a that's a that's a big
question uh that's looking behind the
curtain I guess um it is can you can
reveal yourself as as a method guy um I
know how to switch my method on and off
really well my wife re taught me that
years
ago and you I I dig deep into my soul of
of flaws and good parts and all the
things and I and I I put them all
together and like I call it I like to
puke on a canvas and this one of those
moments where Brock gave me the words to
be able to do just that and the freedom
that you have when you have really great
words to start with the thought process
is right there so it's just The Bravery
of digging deeper than you usually would
for a lot of characters this one by
digging so deep I found so much truth in
myself and in my character and in the
environment and everything that was
around me and it made
for a heck of a psychoanalysis of my my
life and myself and my place on Earth
and how much I adore God and how much I
appreciate and I'm humbled by the gifts
that he has given me he's given me this
amazing wife re of 20 years and five
kids and hund and something movies and
thousands of hours of Television all
culminating into this last performance
of of the shift which I'm so stinking
proud of I can't even put it into words
that they chose me to to to play this
character and I was not going to let any
anybody down and I don't think I did no
and it's a it's a really special
performance and I'm excited for people
to see it and it's cool it means so much
to you to hear that um Brock there's
some really great special effects in
this film so what would you say to
upcoming directors who kind of worry
about doing sci-fi because of cost like
is there a way that maybe they don't
stop themselves because of that reason
yeah well I think I think if you're
you're going your first time out
generally speaking nobody's going to
give you a ton of money and certainly
that didn't happen with us but but um I
think there I think there's a real space
for Grounded sci-fi and and to me
grounded sci-fi means a world takes
place in a world that's probably a
little bit more familiar to us um but
sci-fi to me it's not about the special
effects it's about the ideas it's it's
about the Mind expanding possibilities
that science fiction offers us and that
doesn't need a big budget and that
doesn't need fancy special effects and I
think audiences especially this year
have told us you know what we've seen at
all at this point the effects uh are are
great but they're not they're not the
whole thing and we need more than that
we want something to chew on and that's
what we hope we've delivered with this
movie is that is that we've given you
something to chew on something that'll
provoke conversation uh and uh and from
the early response we've gotten it seems
that's how people are receiving this and
um very few people are talking about the
effects but they're talking about your
performance and they're talking about
Chris paa's performance and they're
talking about um the the really core
ideas about family and relationships and
faith and difficulty and uh and and this
big big universe and and what what is it
all about well it's also it's it's a
different time of film making you know
two of my favorite films as a kid were
the French Connection J Hackman's
performance as papy papy Doyle was just
kind of flawless that he was like the
seventh or eighth choice to play papy
Just cracks me up was he really I know
Newman and Redford and they went through
the whole list of course uh and also
Heaven Can Wait uh I think is Warren
Batty's greatest film and greatest
performance and greatest Direction all
those things so you you take that with a
faith backdrop and that's basically kind
of what we did with this film we took
very dark issues about life you know
they dragged the lead character of this
film Kevin played by the amazing
Christopher palaha through hell for five
years of Agony and yet there was this
backdrop of Heaven Can Wait in the
background of something else out there
is bigger than us something else out
there is greater than us and the only
place where you could have made this
film was where you made it and that's
Angel Studios 100% that they allow us to
tell stories where Faith films were
always so kind of sweet
and not
multi-dimensional years ago but because
of Angel we get to tell stories about
real life problems and flaws and sin and
addictions and pain and loss and all
these things yet at the end of the film
you have a feeling of Hope and it's that
amplification of light that that angel
really shoots for instead of the dark
landscape that Hollywood has become I
think that's why sound of Freedom did so
well because people are are craving that
kind of entertainment so this weekend if
you can you want to see this on a big
screen because it's such a beautiful
film but it tells Hollywood the more
tickets that we buy this weekend it
tells Hollywood okay enough with just
this awfully dark stuff I want my family
to go to see a film that we can all talk
about after and that's what we did the
other night my five kids after and
they're all younger kids are like Dad
that movie was awesome I love this I
love that I love this you can't do that
in most films now because they're just
so dark and thank you Angel for giving
Brock the ability to take his baby and
let it come to fruition so hey Bravo
dude well and to you as well it is out
now in theaters the shift thank you guys
so much for joining me today hope
talking you in the future thanks Steve